[Musica]
Grazie mille Buongiorno a tutti Grazie
mille per essere qua mi ero preparato un
discorso Spero di ricordarmelo tutto
perché vorrei toccare tanti punti con
voi Innanzitutto mi presento sono Griffa
Paolo sono chef proprietario del polo
Griffa caffè Nazionale in centro d'Aosta
e fa parte dei locali storici italiani
aperto nel 1800 proprio come bar come
luogo di incontri e dopo Adesso è un
anno che abbiamo aperto ed era rimasto
chiuso dopo un periodo di inattività in
questo periodo abbiamo rifatto tutto un
restauro conservativo dove Grazie Erano
riusciti a riportare al suo antico
splendore perché c'erano tanti affreschi
della Cappella di San Francesco sotto
quindi è ritornata veramente a
risplendere di nuovo luce però non
abbiamo voluto snaturarlo abbiamo voluto
mantenerla la sua identità abbiamo
voluto mantenere focale la parte barla
parte centrale come luogo di
convivialità abbiamo aggiunto quello che
la pasticceria che è una grandissima
passione per me e quindi dalle colazioni
merende aperitivi ma nelle sale
principali visto che erano molto belle
abbiamo siamo andati aggiungere quello
che era un ristorante un ristorante e al
di sotto di esso nell'interrati una
cucina molto attenta a quello che era
l'impatto ambientale tecnologico Infatti
è completamente elettrica per
raccontarvi quello che abbiamo fatto a
raccontarvi successi che avevamo
ottenuto avremo un giro un po' più ampio
voglio proprio andare analizzare con voi
andare a scomporre quello che è la
nostra attività e raccontarvela sotto
diversi aspetti così per farvela capire
meglio però dobbiamo partire in realtà
da qualcosa che conosciamo tutti mi
piace sempre fare come esempio la pasta
pomodoro e basilico Perché sembra la
cosa più made in Italy che abbiamo
sembra proprio un Baluardo dei made in
Italy riconosciuto in tutto il mondo a
noi sembra una cosa di familiare
qualcosa di quotidiano qualcosa di
normale Ma siamo sicuri che è così che
rappresenti veramente l'italianità
Dopotutto gli spaghetti vengono
raccontati per la prima volta a 4000
anni fa in Cina e sarà poi soltanto che
Marco Polo metterli in Europa come
tradizione così come il basilico in
realtà indiano thailandese e sarà
Alessandro Magno nel 350 a portarlo in
Europa anche Esso come un prodotto
straniero e poi i pomodori però sappiamo
tutti e sta arrivando l'America con
Cristoforo Colombo però in cucina non li
andremo a utilizzare fino alla fine del
XVIII secolo quindi come possiamo
definire un piatto di spaghetti con
pomodoro e basilico un piatto
tradizionale italiano secondo me in
realtà lo è perché racconta proprio
quello che è la nostra cultura racconta
la cultura di un popolo che ama
viaggiare e super curioso apprende molto
facilmente e riporta sempre in un
territorio che è ricchissimo super
Prospero e qualunque ingrediente che
riesce a portare e a fare proprio lo
rende un'eccellenza Quindi secondo me
questa la pasta banalmente chiamata
pomodoro e basilico racconta
l'italianità nel mondo perché racconta
il nostro modo di fare il nostro stile
di vita
Quindi con questa premessa come possiamo
fare di territorio di una cucina di
territorio una cucina locale quando in
realtà siamo da sempre abituati a
scambia contaminazioni a prodotti e a
culture che arrivano da qualunque parte
del mondo come si fa a definire quindi
una cucina locale Questo è un po' il
quesito che ci siamo posti quando siamo
arrivati a Courmayeur perché io non sono
Valdostano sono piemontese E quindi
volevo che quando le persone arrivavano
qua in questo bellissimo territorio
potessero portare con sé un ricordo
potessero provare qualcosa che trovano
soltanto qui perché non è solo fare
buona cucina quando la gente mangia non
viene soltanto per passare del tempo con
gli amici davanti a una buona bottiglia
di vino va bene Viene anche per questo
però mentre mangia si approccia a dei
prodotti questi prodotti raccontano i
produttori che li hanno fatti raccontano
dei ricordi di pensieri delle tradizioni
che ce ne sono dietro quindi per noi è
fondamentale quando vengono a mangiare
da noi che quando vadano via si portino
un pezzetto di questo racconto
Ovviamente ognuno di noi fa delle
racconti soggettivi perché E come lo
vedo io e come lo vede un altro mio
collega quindi non sarà mai un assoluto
questo perché arriva da diverse
tradizioni radicate in noi perché io
come diciamo sono piemontese Quindi
quando sono arrivato qua ho dovuto
conoscere questa tradizione all'inizio
quando era arrivato non conoscevo le
tradizioni d'abitudine i prodotti locali
ho dovuto conoscerli e a prenderle piano
piano e far le mie però c'è una
questione di fondo gli faccio un esempio
io sono da piemontese se parliamo di
insalata russa facciamo un ingrediente
che conosciamo tutti sono pochissimi
ingredienti per me sono patate sono
piselli sono carote una buona maionese
finito lì perché tradizionalmente mi è
stato insegnato si fa così lo mangio da
sempre mia nonna fa benissimo quindi
Questi sono gli ingredienti non
chiamerei mai insalata russa un piatto
con sottaceti olive acciughe per quanto
buona possa essere questa è la sua
grande forza la tradizione e si è
radicata in noi nei gesti nelle
abitudini nei quelle cose che ti vengono
insegnate e che si fortificano in te che
ti eridicano questo è giusto e questo è
sbagliato però molto grande limite
perché a volte non ti permette di vedere
a 360 gradi il come mai viene fatto così
il perché ti è stato insegnato in questo
modo Quindi da questo punto di vista per
me è un vantaggio quando mi approccio
alla cucina valdostana perché non ho dei
riti non ho dei gesti che mi dicono
questo piatto si fa così Bisogna
ottenere questo risultato ovviamente
quando lo vai a studiare impari un gusto
che vuoi ottenere Ma poi dopo lo
analizzi più analiticamente quindi
analizziamo gli ingredienti da dove
arrivano come mai vengono utilizzati un
ingrediente piuttosto con altro come mai
culturalmente si utilizzano questi
prodotti perché si fa in questo periodo
perché c'è una stagionalità perché in un
paese si fa in un modo perché in un
paese si fa in un altro anche perché
dopotutto noi ci siamo evoluti siamo
adottati Ormai il nostro fabbisogno
energetico è cambiato completamente non
abbiamo più bisogno di milioni di kcal
per andare poi dopo a lavorare quindi
mangiare è diventato un piacere è
diventato un momento che ci dedichiamo e
quindi anche trasmettere un messaggio
sempre qualcosa di molto
molto importante soprattutto quando lo
fai in un momento rilassato in un
momento libero della tua vita anche
perché rimarrà molto più segnato nella
tua memoria Quindi alla fine siamo un
po' degli ambasciatori ci facciamo guide
dove portiamo i turisti che vengono da
noi magari da tutto il mondo in questo
percorso attraverso il cibo a raccontare
un territorio a raccontare
dei prodotti e dei produttori questo per
noi è fondamentale quello che cerchiamo
di fare tutti i giorni Quindi come
dicevamo sarà soggettivo Quindi quando
volete conoscere veramente una persona
che opera in questo settore quando
proverete dei sui piatti li trasmetterà
anche qualcosa quindi se vi volete
conoscere meglio Ci vedremo poi dopo
l'aperitivo dove abbiamo preparato dei
piatti ma vi aspetto giù da Aosta grazie
mille
[Applauso]